hola qué tal es un gran placer estar con
ustedes nuevamente como todos los
viernes y como todo el fin de semana
hoy en la represa cibernética luis
laborda rufo valencia leonardo gimeno y
pablo goma en barrios les presentamos el
castor cibernético de este viernes 23 de
febrero en vivo y en directo por
facebook live y en nuestro sitio
resident net punto sea y les recordamos
también que este programa lo podrán
escuchar también en nuestro sitio
internet
rc y net puntos ya el sábado 24 y el
domingo 25 de febrero esta versión que
escucharán el fin de semana en nuestro
sitio internet tendrá la música agregada
que no le podemos poner acá en la
emisión en directo un caluroso saludo a
todas y todos un placer estar con
ustedes y bueno leo no le va
[Risas]
y luís bienvenidos muchísimas gracias y
como se han dado cuenta tenemos visita
en el estudio hoy acá en el castor
cibernético francés voltaire director
del centro internacional de
documentación e información haitiano
caribeña y afro canadiense cívica
historiador politólogo y cineasta
haitiano canadiense bienvenidos france
gracias bienvenido a todos los que
visionan este programa y tengo tenemos
también a jean marie hollywood jolie ya
estoy cambiando lo estoy rebote
rebautiza llamar y murió lee traductor y
profesor en el departamento de gestión y
tecnología de la universidad de quebec
en montreal está correcto
no soy traductor de matemáticas
matemático
yo traduje en el libro pero
y ojo que esta última vez
arriesga más especialmente tratándose de
de poesía a la poesía lo más difícil
para traducir en qué cámara estamos en
esta bueno este es el libro del que
estamos hablando es un libro del que
vamos a hablar hoy de poesías de ya que
vivo renovamos a hablar con nuestros
oyentes con todos ustedes y los
invitados acá sobre el libro mapa tree
mi patria mis dos patrias mi isla que
fue editado por el cívica el centro que
en francés voltaire dirige bueno
bienvenidos a todos y vamos a comenzar
este castor cibernético como solemos
hacerlo de costumbre pero las
intervenciones van a ser un poco más
cortas con respecto a alguna noticia o
algo inédito algo inédito la noticia que
me mató en realidad y valga
la manera de expresar lo es la posición
de el presidente de eeuu con respecto a
la utilización de armas por los mares
por parte de los maestros para evitar
matanzas que dice la pomposa calabaza
que hay que que hay que armar a los
maestros para que si entra un loco los
maestros pueden matarlo antes de que el
loco más de alumnos las soluciones a
armar a la gente se produzca masacres
bueno hay al respecto un testigo de la
última balacera como en eeuu dijo
confirmó en todo caso que el personal de
seguridad del colegio donde se produjo
el último tiroteo no participó para
intentar evitar el mismo así que desde
ese punto de vista parece ser que la
teoría del presidente no va a funcionar
demasiado sí y una de las cosas que más
le duele al presidente de los eeuu es
que uno de los héroes de esta terrible
masacre acontecía en eeuu fue un joven
venezolano de 15 años porque fue la
héroe fue uno de los héroes porque
el asesino entraba con su ametralladora
a un aula y este muchachito de 14 años
hijo de venezolanos
se interpuso cerró la puerta otro
profesor lo ayudo recibió cinco tiros de
bala está internado pero vivo y el
profesor murió pero gracias a que él se
interpuso y mantuvo la puerta cerrada
para entonces a través de la puerta de
mi valor hacia la puerta para tratar de
abrirla y si hubiera entrado había 30
alumnos hay más que hubiera mandado más
de los 17 que murieron de los 18 bueno
ok rojo alguna noticia que me sorprende
fue justamente esta historia de que los
rusos habrían tratado de meterse alterar
influenciar influir las elecciones en
estados unidos y una entrevista a un
responsable un ex responsable de la cia
de la agencia central de la agencia le
preguntan bueno y así ha intervenido en
otros países
schild y se lo han hecho pero para el
bien para el bien general que había que
impedir el comunismo etcétera no y la
pregunta que le hacen es sí y qué y está
actualmente usted cree que la cia está
interfiriendo en los gobiernos así pues
estamos luego quizás por poder dañar y
ahí está pues toda esta toda esta serie
de acciones que se han sucedido en
honduras
si venezuela bolivia es decir que nos
están escuchando un saludo solemos
saludarlos al final del programa pero
ahora lo estamos está progresando con
estas lágrimas de cocodrilo de eeuu que
se lamenta de que los rusos han
interferido cuando ellos han destrozado
países desde hace décadas de eso se
trata la columna que esta semana
justamente no dejan entrar dos empresas
chinas de teléfonos porque dice que los
chinos están con esos teléfonos pueden
hacer espionaje cuando está comprobado
que ellos lo hacen con todos los
americanos y con un montón de gente más
en alrededor del mundo
entonces no quieren dejar entrar para
que no de espionaje y esos son los redes
de los maestros de soto luis la gorda
bueno simplemente recordarse que estamos
hablando de literatura de traducción
etcétera del lenguaje que esta semana
fue el 21 de febrero más precisamente y
vengo a hacer una entrevista al respecto
el día internacional de la lengua
materna
fue instaurado hace algunos años por
naciones unidas y de cuando se dijo gran
cosa y ya que nosotros que estamos aquí
hablamos otra lengua que nos ninguna las
dos oficiales de las que se habla en
este país o sea sería ya una tercera
estamos aquí con gente que habla francés
que al español etcétera y creo y creo y
en este país está lleno de gente que
habla cientos de otras lenguas y
dialectos bueno recordar que entonces
hay una lengua materna que es la que nos
transmite eso que somos aunque hay un
problema porque tengo tenemos compañeros
de trabajo acá que me explican
justamente que en casa hablan sin
ninguna diferencia el inglés y el
francés entonces cuál es la de no
materna la lengua materna es la lengua
los progenitores pues los dos hablan dos
lenguas son lenguas maternas esas en ese
caso son las lenguas maternas y lo
interesante de esto es que los niños no
deberían hubo una una oleada de gente en
las escuelas de quebec que le decían a
los padres que tenían que hablarles
francés a sus hijos un padre como yo que
aprende el francés que tiene a frente en
francés con un acento o rem horrible
hablándole francés al niño para que se
acostumbre
después salió a la luz que en realidad
no que uno tiene que mantener la lengua
materna justamente y la lengua de origen
de los inmigrantes porque los niños
tienen la capacidad de hacer la
selección y si tienen papás que hablan
una y otra lengua a los niños hacen el
switch automáticamente y no tienen
ningún problema es más está comprobado
de que desarrolla la inteligencia de una
manera muy especial hable una vez
entreviste a un muchacho asiático que me
decía que él estaba criando a sus hijos
en cinco idiomas que estaba muy bien y
los niños no tenían absolutamente
ninguna confusión y podrían así podían
hacer perfectamente la distinción pero
no sean nuestros invitados jean marie
france si ustedes tienen alguna noticia
así que los haya impresionado que los
haya impactado bueno está lo que hablo
leonardo esta declaración de trump e
incluso fue interesante una intervención
de un ex soldado norteamericano que tuvo
mitigó en
el conflicto de afganistán y que dice la
gente no entiende nada cuando está en
una batalla la confusión que hay y que
el común entre entrenado para eso hay
una confusión total así que cree que va
a crear más problemas que si se arman
profesores con armas más muertos pero
creo que todo esto está toda la
influencia de la nr es lo que me parece
interesante para terminar es de hecho la
reacción de los alumnos estudiantes que
empiezan a movilizarse ya interrogar el
papel de la nba en la definición de las
políticas públicas en eeuu con una chica
que le dijo que presos y deseosos ya no
nos sirven para nada y que hay que
actuar no sea pasar directamente a
legislar con respecto al porte de armas
en eeuu llamar y airbag un taxi después
de amar a los profesores
ama a los niños
no puede comprar alcohol puede comprar
tabaco y puede comprar un arma
tranquilamente hablábamos de la national
rifle association y ellos justamente
esta mañana se pronunciaron en contra
porque no sé qué locura le dio a trump
que decía que a lo mejor iba a pasar la
edad de 18 a 21
para poder comprar armas y protestó
formalmente la asociación y dijo que no
que eso no podía ser que se tiene que
quedar a los 18 entonces a partir de los
18 que ya los niños pueden llegar los
muchachos digamos más que los niños
pueden llegar con su revólver ahí en
caso de que haya por ahí en los negocios
el negocio por sobre todo bueno vamos a
vamos a ver aquí vinimos a hablar de
poesía también a una noticia antes de
entrar en la poesía lo que a mí me
resultó bastante interesante e inédito
fue una noticia que leí en nuestro sitio
de radio canadá de una niña que
un estudiante de la escuela secundaria
en abitab y en val d'or en abitibi ella
se llama a ya sigue y esta niña ella
afirma que ella lee 200 libros por año
los 200 libros por año y es porque su
pasión en la lectura y le interesa tanto
la lectura que de alguna forma hizo
presión en la biblioteca municipal de
baldor para que se abriera un lugar para
que los adolescentes pudieran estar
tranquilos y leer en la biblioteca
entonces 200 libros yo yo me quedo
cortísimo
en cuanto a tele al lector pues yo creo
que depende de que se entiende como
lectura porque hay libros que toman años
leer hay libros que realmente toma toma
tiempo entender y en cada lectura
siempre se encuentran cosas nuevas hay
libros que son inagotables pero también
como digo depende de la edad de la
persona interés la forma de leer qué
y al final la pregunta central es para
que se lee no de acuerdo fue patente
tuvo un accidente de auto cuando vive en
argentina y tuve un golpe en la cabeza
fría
unos 500 soles más no leo más fino y
luego un neurólogo y cuando estaba
esperando en el neurólogo tenía 22 años
estaba leyendo la inmortalidad de milan
kundera y la persona mejor estás leyendo
esos cuántos años tienes 22 estás
leyendo eso sin leerlo con orejas 40
ello por qué porque es otra otra visión
otra vida en la relectura como decía
borges es uno de los ejercicios más
interesantes de la lectura tras
encontrarse con viejos amigos brevemente
el directo de la persona que dijo esos
comentarios sobre la cia y sus
operaciones actuales
y si el ex director de la cia james
woolsey y fue una entrevista que él dio
a fox en un indicó que la si anda
haciendo sus cositas por ahí sí pero que
no los molesten spears y sobre todo
hasta a la hora de este programa nos
hicimos muy atentos
entonces regresamos ahora sí a mi patria
mis dos baterías mi isla que es este
libro que fue publicado recientemente
por las ediciones de cívica ya marc y tú
me dijiste que tú no eres traductor
conejero pero tú has traducido un libro
de poesía y de si hablamos de un grado
de dificultad enorme nada más difícil a
mi juicio que traducir poesía que ha
traducido anteriormente novelas cortas
de una argentina y una agenda secreto de
una bailarina del hongo
entonces porque no quiere que te llame
traductor
la pregunta sería entonces como como
describe cómo se escribe usted en ese
ejercicio
bueno tenía que hacerlo porque
como decía la historia de este poeta es
una historia ética
y no se puede no puedo hablar de la
historia de la joven sin hablar de su
vida
porque él tuvo una vida muy trágica
y él salió de ahí y a los 6 años vida
con ocho hermanos y hermanas con sus
padres exiliados
tuvieron que exiliarse
en 1948
salió de haití pnh después que su
hermano mayor fue linchado
y linchado por partidores del gobierno
pues no es algo casual
y fueron a república dominicana sabiendo
las dificultades que había en ese
momento entre haití y la república
dominicana
y la matanza la masacre de los haitianos
y dominicanos de origen haitiano tuvo
lugar en 1929 3757 después llega algo
muy muy muy fresco y 11 años después
tienen el refugio en la república en la
misma república dominicana y el precio
ahí y a los 23 años el ejército
americano y claro a la república
dominicana como se sabe y él se enfrentó
a los marines porque él se incorporó en
el grupo de combatientes
y no a la invasión norteamericana y
traición
él murió a los gang un bate
en un combate contra los marines a los
23 23 años aunque pues es algo realmente
trágico
un paréntesis muy corto en esto tú lo
traduje este del francés al español o
del español andrés en el español del
foro se escribió en español explicado
que aunque era hablaba bien francés
porque él
antes de morirse
estaba el profesor de francés en santo
domingo pero el escritor arturo en
español
yo quiero destacar una cosa porque
cuando uno hacer la traducción dicen los
que saben que es uno de los trabajos más
comprometidos que uno está reescribiendo
no solamente traduciendo en este caso él
se pone
contra la pared porque está la versión
en francés al lado o sea que uno puede
comparar el que habla francés y español
puede comparar los dos textos al mismo
tiempo que es algo sumamente especial si
salimos publicar el libro de bilingüe lo
hicimos también cuando publicamos años
atrás el modelo latino porque decía que
es imposible no tener las dos versiones
y no es pero en cualquier otro país yo
creo que es importante cuando tú tiene
que traducir un poeta o una canción
da la oportunidad al lector de poder
comparar porque efectivamente es una
reinterpretación de la traducción
así que es interesante para nosotros
hacerlo en los dos idiomas y la decisión
fue editorial fue cívica se pusieron de
acuerdo
quisimos de acuerdo no pudimos de
acuerdo para mí era muy importante
ofrecer al lector francés la posibilidad
de comparar al que por lo menos leía
español igual que quiere aprender la
mayor muy bien y entonces ya que vio
corre no muere a los 23 años esto él lo
escribió en qué momento de su vida
los sus poemas la mayoría de sus poemas
los escribió cuando tenía 20 o 21 años
y hay una madurez muy grande en su
poesía su poesía no es poesía de un
chico de 20 años
y por ejemplo el título el título dice
mucho porque tiene un poema que se llama
estoy tratando de hablar de mi patria
y empieza a mi patria bueno claro que
está y tiene no nunca nombra a haití
pero claro
se sobreentiende pero en un momento dice
quizás voy a hablar de ambos
porque tengo dos patrias y esos son esas
palabras vienen textualmente de su muy
bueno mi padre y mis dos patrias isla
franz y tú ya conocía ya que sucedió
yo hace mucho tiempo me interesaba mucho
por la república dominicana es de mucho
yo diría
desde adolescente pero más que eso fue
en chile con él
que tuve muchos amigos dominicanos
cuando estudiaba en chile y después
bueno con mi visita en la república
dominicana y ya yo lo conocía y conocía
a la gente que lo conocieron gente que
incluso pelearon con él porque hay que
decir también jiang yu tuvo un honor que
publicamos el decreto en el libro que el
comandante caamaño
pero no le dieron la ciudadanía y
últimamente lo que gana aquí es el
decreto pero para mí era interesante
porque traducirlo porque no lo conocían
mucho en haití sabor lo que hablaban
español y era hacer justicia hacer
conocer el hombre pero conocer
principalmente a la obra y es
interesante a otra traducción que se
está haciendo también así que yo diría
como que se está redescubriendo el
cambio a partir también de una situación
en la república dominicana hoy
que dura desde los 10 últimos años de
desnacionalización de los haitianos
entonces resaltar la figura de javier
importante y lo hicimos también en
colaboración con la fundación con vos
porque matías bosch que es el nieto de
fondos estaré trabajando con la obra de
juan bosch y él tiene una perspectiva de
tratar de que frente a los discursos
antihaitiano a la que yo diría una
extrema derecha
trata de venir con otra perspectiva y en
ese sentido importante también que los
haitianos conocen a cambio muy bien
llamar y para ti cuál fue el principal
desafío de hacer esa traducción
el desafío de la interpreta
su voz sin tradicional es porque por
ejemplo
un ejemplo
su poema más conocido es nada permanece
tanto como el llanto
hay varias porque hay varias
traducciones de este título y mi propia
su acción es distinta a las demás porque
corresponde realmente algo que
pienso que él estaba pensando porque no
puedo como yo le dije yo puedo no puedo
separar
la obra diario de su vida porque él
también cuando él habla habla de también
de su vida pero como un poeta no es como
un ensayista pues no nombra las cosas
pero hay quien te aprieta hay que
entenderlas por ejemplo yo voy a leer
a darles un ejemplo
ahí en ácido
de ahí para que de ahí para ti atado a
la sangre sólo después de los años
descubrí en mi pecho la mancha aguja
entonces aprendí a leer en las hojas
a hablar con la tierra y acá ya cuando
ella le construía la historia de los
muchos muertos que la sustentan de la
sangre que alimentó sus frutas del
llanto que sostuvo la precocidad de sus
montes
no es poesía de un chico de 20 años pero
alguien es poesía de alguien que ha
vivido mucho y que ha sufrido mucho pues
en su poema insignia nada permanece
tanto como el llanto
bueno la particularidad de los poetas me
hace pensar de alguna forma en que me
digan que escribió el poeta que me canse
que todos acá conocemos y que escribió
toda su obra durante su adolescencia
entonces y bueno cuando uno lee por
ejemplo de beso
entre otros poemas en el icahn hay una
profundidad ahí que bueno me hace pensar
justamente a eso no a la intensidad que
vivió esos veinte años para poder
escribir
si hay algún comentario ya de nuestra
gente que nos está
nelson contra el ring con buenos días
saludos desde barranquitas destacada su
participación en los juegos olímpicos a
la de canadá anoche vi una competencia
no hicieron 12 oro y plata
lipo morena dice saludos soy de méxico y
después yo nihuil y navarra muchos 79
todos a todo el diverso grupo de la
cabina desde sudamérica en lima perú ya
disfrutando del programa aquí con la
diversidad construimos un perú para
todos el 27 de mayo se conmemora el día
de las lenguas originarias del perú y en
1975 con el reconocimiento del quechua
como lengua oficial de la república y la
publicación de su decreto que instaura
el día del idioma nativo maría herrera
dice hola alegría de verlos y compartir
ustedes con ustedes nuevamente este
hermoso programa de desarrollo de
argentina
me decía que no se distinguía el libro
puse el título del libro y patrias mis
dos patrias mi isla y nos agradece por
la aclaración esa es la gente que estaba
interactuando con nosotros en este
momento muy bien ustedes de ruffo
[Risas]
justamente cuando la excepción tiene
bueno si week en español es que está en
república dominicana y tiene en mente al
lector dominicano
qué recepción tiene en haití y se conoce
decía que lo conoce poca gente pero
y cree que este tipo de personaje
serviría como para para poner en
contexto para o para repensar esta
antigua herida de esta de este profundo
racismo que entre en de república
haitiana hacia haití y esa y ese
discurso de negación de la negritud en
la propia república dominicana
pero muy complejo porque
es un discurso que aparece formalizado
a partir de lo que yo llamaría el mito
de enriquillo es decir de eliminar la
herencia africana privilegiando una
herencia mítica la de los taninos
y donde uno se construye casi esta
identidad como lo que se llamaba el
indio oscuro es decir de lo negro se
borra para plantear en otra imagen hay
que entender esto también qué pasó con
por la época de lo que se llamó en la
historiografía dominicana la dominación
haitiana hay la matanza de trujillo
entre medio 1937
el decreto que elimina 250.000 haití
dominico-haitianos de la nación
dominicana dominicanos de origen
haitiano y el modelo y hay al modelo de
desarrollo que de la agroindustria
era el turismo que utiliza una mano de
obra barata entonces que hay medios y
analistas ultranacionalista y diría yo
que los castigos por ejemplo que
alimentando un discurso ante el piano
pero en la realidad es una situación muy
compleja
haití desde los 20 últimos años desde el
punto de vista económico
casi el segundo mercado para la
república dominicana de más de 2 mil
millones de dólares de intercambio que
benefician a república dominicana así
que en algún momento los medios
económicos alimentan stoker así que es
una situación muy compleja resaltar
figuras como las de vio creo que es
importante como las otras figuras pero
juro sonia pierre que murió que era una
defensora de derechos humanos dominica y
diana pero también yo de la cne view me
parece interesante porque no solamente
es la figura heroica pero también es la
de un gran escritor ahora para la
literatura haitiana
era una figura que no hace parte del
mundo literario haitiano porque no era
conocido no había traducciones de lugo
creo que en una revista que publicamos
se me critique a mari había publicado un
poema un tal y para agregar un par de
que es nada de poemas pero ahora
importante porque este trabajo hija
maría y también otro trabajo de una
dominicana sufí maríñez que está
saliendo también otro libro sobre vio y
creo que es importante resaltar estas
figuras porque en el grupo que estaba
ligado con view hubo los hermanos
batista dos hermanos que murieron en la
cárcel en lugar y que ellos alimentaron
una resistencia y una guerrilla primero
en 64 después fueron capturados
murieron en la cárcel así que yo creo
que estas figuras son importante
resaltar como la de peña gómez que
también fue una personalidad que fue de
un rescatado porque fue adoptado por una
familia dominicana fue un rescatado de
la masacre y creo que es importante
estudiar nuestros periodos pero para un
poco ir más allá de estos discursos que
están de moda en toda parte que es un
evento aparte no es el reflejo lo que
llamaría identitario y es importante
ahora es hacer conocer que hay otra
alternativa al entrenamiento no es
laporta tienes alguna pregunta cuando
hablamos de literatura de poesía de
traducción e interpretación tenemos que
referirnos necesariamente a quienes
desde el punto de vista del lector de
los amantes de la literatura sostienen
que las obras deben ser leídas en su
lenguaje original porque con la
traducción se degrada y se pierde que
está de acuerdo si se pierde
personalmente algunas veces yo leo por
ejemplo yo yo tuve una historia
interesante con la gaseosa leyendo los
primeros libros de vacaciones que
acumula casa verde que es nacional y los
perros de la ciudad es que son muy
difíciles no pero me acuerdo leyendo la
gaseosa en español y en francés al mismo
tiempo para ver cómo el traductor
interpretó el pensamiento de de vagas
llosa en al mismo tiempo utilizando este
conocimiento para entender mejor lo que
él escribió en español
y me parece que con una traducción a
veces es posible entender mejor el texto
original porque tiene una comparación y
tiene una lectura tiene un análisis
totalmente verdad hay una comparación
entre dos puntos de vista sobre el mismo
el mismo texto pero lamenta digo
afortunadamente esa esa degradación que
podría haber acá pues tú tienes la
oportunidad de como señalaba leonardo de
que lo tienes en la lengua original y lo
tienes en español en español y en
francés nuestros días
de tu mismo de reconstruir de alguna
forma de cilia y ahora con la
publicación de los libros por su firma
líneas y su grupo uno tendrá dos puntos
de vista sobre el mismo texto además lo
bueno para un autor es que básicamente
la traducción se dice que
rector cuando escribe es como la persona
que está cantando en la ducha pero
cuando traducen está cantando en la
catedral y además hay que entender
también que jacques vio viene de una
familia muy letrado donde el padre que
era abogado pero vivió en santo domingo
como profesor de grandes ganancias
también
y yang yo tenía que vivir no solamente
antes dos patrias pero también ante tres
idiomas
porque también está la otra parte que el
idioma creo así que es interesante ver
como en la traducción estos idiomas
buena moodle modular
su lengua española porque el español es
un lenguaje literario pero también es un
hombre que vive entre tres idiomas y
seguramente en su casa vive entre el
francés que es el idioma familiar al que
se hablaba pero también con el creo
ahora sí que es un sería interesante ver
eventualmente con la traducción creo
bueno es una temática transversal no en
todas nuestras vidas esas personas que
estamos alrededor de esta mente estamos
todos funcionando yo en mi casa mi
esposa es francófona y
habla un poco de español pero los
intercambios se hacen en francés
efe no fue así desde entonces pues hay
todas las lenguas que están vamos a
regresar al tema pero porque el tiempo
pasa como agua entre los dedos y vamos a
mencionar muy rápidamente los temas que
queremos resaltar esta semana a nuestros
oyentes luis laborda tú nos explicas o
nos hablas más bien de una expedición
polar en bicicleta para la integración
de los inmigrantes sí exactamente este
es un país de inmigración entre otras
cosas y cuando se habla de inmigración
se habla de integración y de ver cómo se
suma a esos inmigrantes a su nueva
sociedad y hay un organismo que se llama
a motivaciones que ha encontrado una
fórmula novedosa original que es la de
invitar a 17 jóvenes inmigrantes
recientemente llegados al país desde
participar de esta expedición polar se
le dice un poco graciosamente real no es
al polo norte que se está viajando es un
trayecto que se hace en bicicleta
durante cuatro días entre montreal y
québec y estos jóvenes van visitando
distintas escuelas
se encuentran a lo largo de este
trayecto y encontrándose con mil jóvenes
que estudian en esos colegios para
intercambiar experiencias y para
comenzar a conocer en el terreno de que
se trata de este nuevo país al que han
llegado entonces esta expedición en la
cabeza de ellos yo creo que es polar por
que la idea surgió precisamente en el
juego de palabras en que se lanza este
pequeño viaje en pleno invierno aquí
para gente que en algunos casos como el
de una chica colombiana o el de gente
que viene de áfrica no están
acostumbrados a este tipo de
temperaturas y entonces salir a
enfrentar ese invierno es por un lado
curados de espanto de entrada digamos y
por otro lado de enfrentarse a una
realidad que puede ser bastante cruda
incluso para los que ya llevamos hace
algunos años en bicicleta transporte
circular así que esta expedición polar
les permite a ellos conocer de entrada
de un saque es el frío país al que han
llegado bueno en rcn punto sea para los
que quieran tener más detalles con
respecto a este reportaje y entrevistas
de luis laborda rufo valencia tú nos
hablas de la batalla
a mejorar el salario mínimo aquí en
canadá
justamente primero de enero en la
provincia de ontario que es la más
populosa del país el salario mínimo
aumentó a 14 dólares y esta idea del
seremi nos abre una puerta mayor que es
justamente que significa un salario
mínimo y qué diferencia y por ejemplo
con un salario mínimo vital entonces en
el artículo hacemos referencia como
aparece esta noción hace unos 100 años
justamente como medida para proteger a
mujeres y niños de la explotación pero
la idea no era que sean totalmente
dependientes entonces hay ahora otras
ideas como por ejemplo plantear que
cuanto justo cuánto se necesita para
poder vivir es decir no solamente
sobrevivir sino vivir y el salario
mínimo varía de una provincia diferente
por ejemplo en montreal en que ve que
está un poco no llega a los 15 a los 14
dólares todavía en la provincia de
limarí todos el 75 en la provincia de
alberta va a subir a 15 dólares en
octubre de este año si es es que no hay
un salario mínimo nacional
y pues esto abre justamente el debate
central es este qué quiere decir sabe
mínimo para qué sirve y qué diferencia
que consta de un mínimo vital y juán
mínimo puede ser para que la gente pueda
sobrevivir claro es justamente en
ontario decían que un salario mínimo
para vivir tendría que ser por lo menos
de 18 o 19 dólares por hora bueno y
leonardo si menos turnos nos hiciste es
un avance ahorita y lo que yo estoy
viendo detrás de toda esta política
estadounidense con respecto a huawei que
es chino estos teléfonos y son dos meses
en cerrar el cercado
zte son dos marcas y en realidad toda la
historia empezó con la repatriación de
apple porque apple tiene sus fábricas en
el exterior y muchas en oriente entonces
lo que hizo el presidente eeuu fue poner
como ciertas trabas para la
comercialización de estos aparatos para
hacerlos volver y que la producción sea
en eeuu para controlar un poco también
la producción
entonces se desvío con apple y se fue
para estos dos grandes constructores
chinos huawei y zte y hay seis agencias
de las más conocidas con el fbi y la cia
la n sea todas hicieron la reunión y
presentaron un informe diciendo que como
esa empresa particularmente huawei y zte
está en relación el uno de los
fundadores estuvo en el partido
comunista entonces dicen que tiene
relación con el gobierno y podrían estar
robando información bueno eres en el
punto o sea yo por mi parte los invito a
escuchar una entrevista que hice con un
escritor quebequense que se llama
camille buscar y que escribe bastante
literatura para los jóvenes y su último
acaba de publicar su última novela que
se llama pistolero sí y me llamó la
atención pistolero entonces estuve
estuve conversando con él
el pistolero él cuenta en cuenta la
historia de un padre de familia que se
va se lleva a su hijo adolescente que
debe tener unos 13 años estamos hablando
de mil 923 más o menos en la época en
plena revolución mexicana entonces este
padre de familia quiere que su hijo viva
emociones fuertes y se lo lleva para
gméxico nada más y nada menos que para
que se encuentre con pancho villa
entonces pues es la historia de
pistolero la entrevista la pueden
escuchar en rcn punto osea
desafortunadamente el tiempo como decía
se nos está yendo y se nos fue
prácticamente una última ronda leonardo
maría herrera dice como poniendo como
conozco gracias a sus programas gracias
por permitirnos a la distancia compartir
sus programas
jon y willy navarros y saludos o triunfo
vimos el saludo en la cabina y javier
gonzález nungaray dice muchos amigos
ordiales 73 en el castor cibernético
a los invitados muy bien para terminar
una última intervención francés para
terminar yo diría que es interesante
este libro por dos razones la primera se
sabe que desde los diez últimos años a
un fenómeno nuevo que es la inmigración
haitiana hacia chile y disminuyó
recientemente hacia argentina y brasil
también una parte pero estoy hablando si
entonces algún fenómeno totalmente nuevo
que es la presencia haitiana mayor en
chile yo cuando estudian sin la unión
del 60 ayer éramos 20 21 21 y ahora hay
más de 120.000 hay como 50 mil en
argentina lo mismo en brasil así que un
fenómeno totalmente nuevo que es
interesante descubrir y hay mucho
trabajo que se están haciendo de
descubrimiento la literatura y diana de
traductor y que hasta una editora
chilena descubrí llama a ambos editores
que traduce obras literarias haitianas
en chile - fantástico
hummer y para
muy rápidamente bueno estoy muy contento
de haber podido terminar este trabajo y
también debido al apoyo de france fue
muy difícil conseguir los textos porque
hubo muchos textos en español de poemas
de vino pero conseguir los nueve fácil
está tomando la américa latina por
asalto en los controles técnicos hoy son
tal saints o ver aquí en la represa pues
les agradezco inmensamente a jean marie
de france por la visita acá en el
estudio y el castor cibernético y
gracias a nuestros colegas rojo lo es
leonardo espera hasta la semana próxima
y bueno como solemos así la música como
les decía que va a estar en el montaje
la música será estar a cargo del grupo
work of the earth que vamos a comenzar
el programa con la canción hard y sing y
se vuelvan y continuamos con 6 voz y
cerramos con clean bout york
war of the arts bueno eso fue todo para
este programa del castor cibernético de
este finde de este viernes y del fin de
semana
muchísimas gracias a todos muchísimas
gracias a que en estudio chao
ya hay los espías que hay saludos a la
de necesidad ya todos sus amigos ni
hacer daño
adiós